this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's up you Savages it's Monday
the 10th of April the joint is brought
to you by DraftKings listen it's time
for the NBA playoff that means it's time
to fire up your DraftKings Sportsbook
app and get it on the excitement this
week is going to be great you got
in-house tournament you got the Lakers
the Clippers you got Memphis you lit
tremendous new customers can make a five
dollar pregame moneyline bet and score
150 in bonus bets if that theme wins
Plus everyone can score a no sweat same
game ballet every day during the NBA
Playoffs just like that that's what
DraftKings is doing so open up the
DraftKings Sportsbook app opt-in and
play a same game ballet on any NBA and
if it doesn't hit you're gonna get back
ten dollars who's better than DraftKings
you download the app right now sign up
with code Joey j-o-e-y new customers can
make a five dollar pregame moneyline bet
and score 150 in bonus bets if that team
wins it's that easy only on DraftKings
Sportsbook with code Joey if you got a
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler in
Massachusetts call
1-800-327-5050 or visit
gamblinghelplinema.org
in Kansas call
1-800-522-4700 but if you ain't got a
problem download the app and let's get
ready for the playoffs the joint is also
brought to you by listen April is
testicular cancer awareness month it's
the most common form of cancer in men 15
to 35. one man every hour gets diagnosed
with testicular cancer men hit manscape
has teamed up with the testicular cancer
society to bring awareness to Men's
Health and early cancer detection as
part of that we say boss initiative
check your balls Save Your Balls by
checking for cancer every time you use
your manscape products for a limited
time you can also get a manscape special
edition purple testicular cancer society
lawnmower 4.0 electric waterproof nut
trimmer there are only ten thousand of
these in existence so if you want one
get it now listen you know me guys I
love the lawnmower but this one it's
special it's a purple lawnmower to show
your awareness take care of your balls
of manscape get 20 off plus free
shipping with code Joey at manscape.com
again that's 20 off plus free shipping
with code Joey at manscape.com
let's get this party started guys
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's happening you Savages welcome to
another fun-filled episode of Uncle
Joey's joint it's Monday April
[__] 10th and as usual this
year the train kept rolling they ain't
stopping for [__] nobody you [__]
wake up it's Monday you fall asleep it's
Friday you're like Rip Van Winkle it
really is you don't even know what day
it is no more this shit's just [__]
flying you just take it for what it is
one minute it was Valentine's Day right
next minute was my birthday now we're
talking about Easter [__] uh how
quick is that just like that it's done
now now the next big thing is 420
[__] that's the next big holiday then
you got Mother's Day Father's day then
you got the book but that's not a
[__] holiday
but it's [__] non-stop man so it just
keeps [__] moving great week getting
better and better every [__] week uh
I jumped into technology this week I did
that PRP on my [__] knee and do I
have a BRP on my knee I'm rhyming and
[__] on a [__] Monday morning
tremendous listen guys you know you you
uh
Dean Dean Delray my dear friend got into
a motorcycle accident I don't know years
ago and he hurt his neck
and it was really starting to [__]
around with his well-being after eight
nine years I don't know exactly you know
he went to physical therapy he was in
the hospital but sometimes these things
linger and uh
he spoke to Joe and Joe recommended you
know
a little PRP for his neck I think it was
stem cell and I remember talking to him
and Dean was like dog this was the worst
experience of my goddamn life
he was like adamant about it I go what
happened he goes first off
when they took the blood out it was
[__] like two hours they just sit
there and take blood out of here by the
time you leave there you [__] beat up
and then they shoot it back into you and
they have to shoot it into that spot so
they shot it into his neck I guess
and he says he was laying down
and uh
he [__] fainted
and they're like he didn't they didn't
even think of stopping the process they
just like kind of smacked them in the
face threw some water at him made him
smell some smelling salts and put like a
berry [__] smoothie in his mouth
and he said he was awake while he was
fainting like he was like taking drips
and fainting like a Vietnam vet taking
drips and fainting and he goes finally
he just you know he stopped [__]
fainting from the pain he got used to it
and he came out and he goes it was like
a 20-minute faint-a-thon
so you know I went to the doctor listen
when I did the brand new knee it was a
mistake guys
I wish I would have [__] looked into
it more I really but if I would have
looked into it and investigated it
I wouldn't have done it once I saw the
video of the Mallet and the [__]
hammer in the saw I wouldn't have done
it you know that's just the way it is so
and um then I wouldn't have done it and
then it would have taken me another
eight years to do the [__] PRP
because I was scared I had already done
the knee surgery and I'm like what do I
got to lose so the left knee was the one
that started this whole [__] thing
I said nobody remembers
the last time I did this left knee I
still remember being in at a UFC event
I did something with Rogan on a Friday
night and I didn't go to the UFC event
because I was getting surgery that
Monday
and I was [__] petrified man
and uh
that Monday I woke up went down in the
hospital you know whatever happened
happened
and then months later my wife was
pregnant with Mercy that's when I
started doing the uh
I started working out again you know
when you do the uh
whatever [__] after you have surgery you
know rehab I started squatting the guy
wanted me to squat with one leg and then
squat with two legs I haven't I hadn't
Squad in [__] 30 years so I walked
around with a hard on for like a [__]
three months and then my wife ended up
pregnant because the squats got your
blood going and your legs towards your
testicular
valve whatever it doesn't [__] matter
but that was when it all started and
then over the years I got a shot put in
it and then I did the right knee and
then back to the [__] left knee and
then
I finally got the brand new redone
and my left knee wasn't bothering me at
all
and all of a sudden [__] in January came
and it's like I went zero to 60. I've
been [__] around with this left knee
for months going to Jujitsu riding the
bike doing this doing that walking
[__] Hills behind there and finally
just went kaput so I'm like I I went
back to the doctor Dr Plyler my boy
and he was like listen man you know I
could cut it I could do this that this
but I gotta find that this is his whole
world go see him you're gonna love him
and it's funny when you you know when
you look for recommendations for a
doctor like you ask people that you
trust like somebody who knows that field
or whatever I asked three people in that
field and all of them said the same guy
it was like [__] it was crazy like I
was like really this goddamn like this
is the [__] dude if there's daylight
this guy will give it to you I went down
there spoke to him
it was funny because
when it comes to Needles I'm a [__]
[__] I've been training an acupuncture
for us wow 16 years and every needle I
still got to think about it and [__] but
it's not as bad as it used to you know
it's not as bad as it used to so
you know he's like it's just a little
bit of blood and then it's all done in
one day you have to come back they take
it out they spin it and they shoot it
back into your [__] knee we numb the
knee
they don't even take that much blood out
I said you know what I'll do that I'm
not doing testosterone therapy I'm not
doing all that [__] like I'll do that
for sure and it took me two weeks to go
in there they thought I was gonna check
it out but I made an appointment then I
got sick
and they were like oh here you go
because I tell everybody the truth I'm
scared of needles if I jump out the
window and you show up with the needle
it's not you it's not personal I'm just
scared of needles and [__] so for
[__] Friday morning I woke up my wife
couldn't even go with me usually if my
wife could go with me she goes to hold
my hand and when I faint and [__] so she
prepped me this bag she's like yeah I
got you a a Coke Zero
like a [__] uh peanut butter and
jelly sandwich because if you faint when
you wake up you want to put the sugar in
your body and I go what's that and she
goes she packed the [__] thing of
napkins
thing like a whole package of napkins
and I go what's that what she goes
because your palms are gonna sweat like
a [__] whenever I give blood my
Palms [__] go ballistic I mean
ballistic I had a friend who used to
sweat from his hands he had to go to
doctors
to get a magic medication or something
to stop sweating from his hands it would
[__] drip and that's how my hands are
when I go to the doctor and I'm just
waiting to get the shot when I pick up
my hand it's like five [__] it's like
a handprint on my jeans or on my
sweatshirt it's it's kind of [__]
scary I don't know it's yeah it's a
little bit of anxiety so when I got
there yesterday you know I got there a
little early I talked to the girls in
the office
they called me back that the place was
rocking and rolling you know
so I felt okay you know it's funny as
I'm driving now I'm like what kind of an
[__] am I I'm driving to my own
execution you ever feel like that like
you're like I'm driving through my own
[__] execution
who the [__] is this now it's [__]
I'm driving to my own [__] execution
I'm like God damn it I get that I'm like
I can't believe I'm in here you know
many times in L.A
20 years ago I would go to the doctor's
office and just go home
and my wife would say no I wouldn't go
in and my wife would go how was the
doctor's office today ah it was great
man I'm fine I'm gonna live another 10
years I wouldn't even go in there then
she would find that a year later you
didn't even go what you know so trust me
guys when I drive myself that's one
thing walking through the door
that's another [__] deal that you
know driving there and sitting out there
that's one thing driving in Walking in
the doors nothing I remember walking in
there going
what the [__] am I doing
I sat down they came and got me I walked
me to the back we talked for a little
while
I always bring earplugs you know like
little uh things that I listen to AC DC
or Santana my phone the [__] iPod
finally blew up to 15 years I missed
that [__] thing I had so much
great music on there
I put my little [__] thing on
they both came in they spoke to me the
girl is great less [__] great talked
on the phone with a couple times made me
feel comfortable
came in right
they're talking to me on something like
right here yeah let me put my music on
boom I put my music on when the needle
went in I [__] felt it now that's
what makes me faint is the reaction to
the needle in my mind it's bigger than
what it is you know
so I always go out and I jump a little
bit and then I wait for the fainting to
start but nothing started right like I
didn't feel the faint coming or anything
and I'm like it's all but the pain was
there so I'm like eventually this
[__] faint is gonna go forward
and then I just relaxed
and I looked the other way
and I was [__] fine listen to AC DC
overdose Angus is [__] throwing heat
I overdosed on you I'm getting into it
finally a doctor walks to my side
they're taking blood on my left arm he
walks over to my side
and he's like that's it you're done I'm
like really and we're talking
but I see this [__] nurse still
lingering like she's like [__]
pulling like a rope like she's in the
ship or something like that
pull him pull him pulling like what's
she doing is she still drawing blood he
goes yeah yeah three more minutes listen
guys
10 years ago when I heard three more
minutes
that's it
but I just closed my eyes I let Angus do
his [__] solo
and I looked up and he goes that's it
they put the [__] thing on me do you
know I still haven't taken the Band-Aid
off my leg or my arm because I'm scared
to faint because when I I fainted one
time when I took the Band-Aid off and
just looked at it it was just a DOT of
blood and I got up I haven't even taken
two [__] showers three showers since
then I'm not yeah no like the arm
battery finally fell off the arm [__]
Band-Aid finally fell off but the
[__] leg is still there I don't touch
I got a little swelling
the blood was the only thing that got me
going then I had to wait 45 minutes
while they spin the blood they add the
chemicals to it they had the the thing
from the super shot because it's really
a PRP super shot
so they had some other stuff in there
peptides whatever the [__] malukia juice
I don't know
I waited I thought I spoke that I'm
there very nice they mix the blood in
front of me let me tell you something
when I looked at three ounces of blood
like that's what they took out because
she told me 66 no first they go it's a
little bit of blood
the night before when they called to
confirm she goes make sure you hydrate
because we're taking out like 60 CC's or
something amount I don't know what it is
I just heard CC's and I'm like [__] it
you know I'm like what am I gonna do
because I'm already signed up
and uh they took three ounces out and
she told me to take three ounces because
I saw the
it was a [__] needle with a big thing
on like a silencer it looked like a
[__] I'm like what the [__] you know
I didn't see it before she shot me but
after she took the blood out I'm like
what the [__] did I just do and I told
like you got to stand in front of the
blood I can't see that [__]
dog they spin it they talk to you a
little bit
doctor comes in
and he goes listen I'm going to do this
I don't know what you're gonna feel I'm
gonna make it as comfortable as I can be
I was like all right give it a give it a
[__] go put overdose on little AC DC
again I'm sitting there I feel the
needle going in guys
and for a split second I felt like you
know firecrackers like whatever the [__]
happens
and then
I felt something go in like something he
puts like a
a cooling agent on it like this [__]
dry ice on your leg I mean you could hit
it with a [__] Hammer you won't feel
it like I was hitting it I'm like I
don't feel dick like when I hit it now I
can feel the needle
but when I [__] uh he puts the cream
on there it freezes up guys he shot the
needle in I felt the liquid cocaine
going
and also he goes that's it you're done
and like how can I be done he just shot
the the cocaine in there and he goes no
what I do is I shoot the Coke in there
and then I switch the cartridge so the
needle's still in there and then just
keep going I don't know if I just shoot
the [__] three ounces back into your
[__] leg
guys I'd love to complain you know I'm a
[__] when it comes to Needles and
whatnot I love The [__] I'd love to
tell you not to do it
oh man
I [__] got up I walked out of there
I walked the [__] out and they told me I
was gonna have some problems blah blah
blah
I came home I got home I walked in there
at 10 45.
and I walked out at 11 46.
that's just you know and usually like
I'm the type of guy like you shoot me
with a needle like that I got to sit
down for an hour after that and think
about life and where I went wrong and
[__] and should I call the therapist and
all this [__] but no I got my car I
drove home
they called in some uh pain medication
for me like I thought it was going to be
ibuprofen like 800 or whatever I can
only take Tylenol and they gave me
acetaphetamine
with codeine
does it do anything to you I didn't even
take it
the first day that I can't put ice on it
I can't do nothing on it and that was it
I just figured it must have been where
Dean got it that it hurts so bad yeah it
was the neck and it was it was the other
Pier this is a PRP shot
the other prps and they use a lot of
blood I think I don't know but I know
that they use a big because I talked to
the regular doctor and he's like he goes
you're right the [__] PRP needle
that'll send you into [__] Pluto
you'll get some flashbacks of [__]
Vietnam even though you were never
[__] man I was like well that's not
what I need because like I said I walk
out of those [__] things
the only knock is
Insurance don't cover it because it
works but I gotta be honest with you
I expected to drop like when I took the
numbers they were going to hit me with
which is going to depress me
not at all guys
not at all it was a lot I went in there
with a [__] I'm like they're gonna
[__] put me in Pluto I'm gonna have
to make payments I gotta put on my
credit card no it wasn't that bad Lord I
put on my ATM card and I walked the [__]
out of there
and it feels good it feels really good
to take care of yourself sometimes
you know like it really does like nobody
had to talk me into it nobody had to
beat me up you know this is what needs
to be done and you [__] do it and
that's it you know 20 30 years ago I
wouldn't have done this
I would have bought a brace from
Nighttime television because they tell
you the pain is going to go away put
copper in there whatever the [__] they
do and then uh you know that's what I
would have done I would have never
[__] uh got the surgery done and I'm
happy I'm not this or anything anything
I [__] do I'm happy the next up
colonoscopy and I'm not looking forward
to that one that's a [__] nightmare
no matter how you slap guys it's a
painful no you know what the worst thing
about it is forget like me to [__] IV
they throw in your hand
to have one they have one and
at a doctor's office that's
it's none uh they don't touch it
a computer does it
I forget what it's called I have to look
it up on the computer I have a computer
close to me
but it's like uh yeah her computer does
it
something with an x-ray I really don't
know it's expensive
insurance won't cover it either they
want you to do the the [__] the
manual the [__] finger of your
[__] ass Hey listen man
[Music]
I found out something that I didn't take
care of myself as a youngster whether
it's my teeth you know when I say my
teeth I didn't brush my teeth at night
before I went to bed
just that little thing right there
that matters a ton when you're a comic
and you're doing coke when when you got
some [__] chick sitting on the couch
and she's ready to snort coke you're not
gonna go hold on one second let me brush
my [__] teeth as a matter of fact if
you're snorting good Coke you ain't
gonna feel your [__] teeth you know
what I'm saying so
it's the truth you know right now I look
at all that [__] and I'm like I wish
I would have had somebody to get on me
when I was 20 and 30 to really take care
I didn't even go to a [__] doctor
until I was in my [__] 30s 38 39
that's when I saw the sleep apnea I wish
I would have saw the there was a period
I didn't go to the doctor for maybe 10
years
didn't go to the dentist for like 10
years walked around with an abscess that
you could squeeze it it would shoot
possibly I would sit next to people and
go Rogue and watch this and I would
shoot it and it shoot out of the molar
and it would land on people's shirt they
wouldn't even know what the [__] was
going on I never took care of all that
[__] and if I got a [__] regret
it's [__] not taking kickers now look
at the problems I have with my teeth and
the [__] abscess you know
the knees and [__] listen when you're
out there running and working and you
know taking buses and [__] it's all a
part of what's going on like here my
shoulder hurts what do you want from me
I'm not gonna take the day off because
I'm gonna lose a day's pay you know how
it is right how many times do you not go
to the doctor because you don't want to
lose a day's pay that's the excuse to
give yourself all the time we all do it
don't feel bad we've all done I'm gonna
lose a day's pay I gotta go all the way
to Brooklyn [__] that next thing you
know you look down how did my toe fall
off well you know you were supposed to
go to the doctor three [__] years ago
and you didn't [__] go now with what
I paid for insurance and how much effort
I got to put in to get [__] insurance
are you [__] kidding me I gotta I got
a [__] Splinter and I'm at the
doctor's office well not anymore because
it's [__] hard to get a goddamn
appointment but you know it's not hard
to get an appointment
better out and now for a word from our
sponsors what's up you Savages decepo
this episode is brought to you by better
help getting out of the house to see a
therapist can be real difficult better
help confer your journey to
self-discovery from wherever you are
this is therapy that's entirely online
no waiting in an office you can do
therapy from the comfort of your own
home or literally from your bed I'm not
going to judge you listen
better help Works guys
I did all from the bottom of my basement
down here I spoke to Dana once a week
and she kept me on top Tip Top Magoo
listen better help is convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
fill out a brief questionnaire to get
matched with the licensed therapist and
get on your way to living a better life
if you need a different therapist at any
point you could switch at any chart at
no charge and they'll usually hook you
up with a therapist within 48 Hours
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhealth.com
slash Diaz again
betterhelp.com
Diaz to get 10 off your first month
that's betterhealth.com
Diaz thank you we're back [__] don't
forget to go to better help if you're
feeling weird
if you're feeling like uh yeah man
sometimes you don't know what the [__]
you're feeling
you know you're like I've been sluggish
lately but I don't feel bad I haven't
been sleeping
that's when you give better help a call
they're quick they're reliable and
they'll [__] have somebody for you to
talk to within days and that's it
[__] uh what I want to talk about
this week the Monday motivation
I get a lot of questions
whether it's on patreon whether it's
Twitter Facebook Instagram I think the
number one
question lately that I've been getting
and
my neighbor I was talking to her a
couple days ago
last week and we're talking about one
thing and she's telling me that one of
the girls she went to college with which
I met uh
her brother
is trying to get into stand-up comedy
[Music]
you know she goes he's been doing it for
a while
he's got a great day job he goes out
four or five nights a week
because he just doesn't know
The Next Step
you know
and this is a step that I get it from
Lee I get it from
there's two or three guys on patreon
that are really [__] going for the
stand-ups you know I live vicariously
through them they tell me what they do
and they're at what they don't
understand they're at the best part of
their career
that's the best part of your career if I
look back now and look talk to you guys
from the heart and go what was great
doing Town Hall the Chicago theater
that [__] was all great because after a
while you knew it was gonna happen
but the greatest thing about comedy or
being in a band is when
you
don't know what's gonna happen
you just keep
we rehearse on Thursday nights
okay
we rehearse on Thursday nights and us as
a band we book four gigs a month because
Mike's got a family I got a Fung night
toe nail this guy does this you know and
you you know you
you do the best you can what you got and
then one day somebody sees you somebody
hears your music and it gets serious and
the game is on you know or but you like
Joey
when does it get serious
so anyway to make a long story short we
would talk and and she goes you know I'm
embarrassed to say this to you
but my brother's been doing comedy for a
while
and he wrote this thing you know and I'm
embarrassed to even give it to you
but he asked me if I could and I go
listen
give it to me you know I got it in the
other room I'll give it to me let me
read it and it wasn't the script it was
his jokes you know like a set list and
whatever and he sent like a half a
resume what clubs he played at you know
the
stand and uh stand up New York just [__]
like that you know
so I said you know give me a couple days
and uh yeah I'll reach out to him you
know and talk to him a little bit I mean
I like her a lot I like my neighbor a
lot they're great people [__] smart
as whips
and I gave him a call
and uh
it was a great little conversation man
it got my dick hard
you know because this guy has been out
there he has been going for it
and he's struggling with the window
when do I call clubs when is it okay to
send the tape what is it
and I'm like listen man what's your
situation you gotta tell me your
situation do you have a great day job
he's a Salesman he sells something like
a service he makes great money and after
the pandemic they work from home
so he's like this is my opportunity
I could do this from anywhere I just
don't even know who to call and stuff
like that
and I told him I go right now the clubs
are in you know clubs want to deal with
people who are hot you have to stop you
have to start with D rooms see rooms a
couple B rooms and work yourself up
and eventually you'll get a feature spot
on improv then you'll get another
feature spot another improv then by
mistake this kind of hired a MC at an
improv and next thing you know you're
you're in the chain
it's not going to happen overnight you
know but here's some uh ideas he goes
well I listened to you when you won the
church years ago and you gave us some
ideas about Bookers
and I'm like you know right now in my
point in my life I don't know who's
booking
but I go look up David Tribble that's
that guy David Tribble
should deserve a star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame honest to God the more I
think about David Tribble I have not
worked for David Tribble in close to 20
[__] years okay
over 20 years it's got to be because
that yeah last time I worked for triple
had to be 97 we did comedy in a [__]
tent in Arizona it was 200 degrees
outside and 180 in that thought well the
10th will be cooler yeah because you put
two fans in that it had to be a hundred
and [__] 70 degrees in that tent I
went down there with this committee I
knew from uh Seattle he was the
headliner I was the [__] MC
we had to drive six hours and then do
two shows in the [__] tenth and then
get back in the car and drive all
[__] night we didn't get home till
like five in the morning and I got like
200 in cash it was a [__] glorious
night get the [__] out of here
but it's funny before the pandemic I
could look at you guys and tell you one
thing about my stand-up
comedy I can't tell you if I was funny I
can't tell you that the material was
great but I will tell you something that
was really weird
the last two years before the pandemic
ended I was out there every other
weekend or every weekend and I was out
four or five nights a week when I stayed
home I was starting to notice something
I was starting to notice things I was
doing on stage and going where did I get
that from
where did I learn that when I [__]
get this one when I learned how to pause
anyway I was
throughout the last two years every
weekend
David Tribble would come to my mind
those triple runs
those triple runs when you're doing them
in the beginning
you feel like [__] Guns and Roses I
can't describe the feeling to you
after 10 15 years you look at this [__]
the triple run I'm gonna be doing a lot
of driving and hopefully by that time
your career has moved on but the best
foundation for me there were three
people that were David Tribble was
number one
there was a guy in Texas that I [__]
went to war with
Tia Campbell or something like that that
guy had
you know a week-long run and this is
what you want at that level when you're
when you're doing comedy and you're
stuck at a five-year Point you're really
an emcee you could really feature if you
had the material and the push
but right now you're just getting a week
here a week there a weekend if I
attribute anything
to my comedy uh aggressiveness it was
what I learned on those triple runs
because it's every day
so you get in your car on a Sunday you
get to your destination Monday morning
and you start doing calmly on Tuesday
night and then Wednesday you get up and
drive and another show Thursday you get
up and drive another show Joey that
doesn't sound like fun
it's work if you really want to do it if
you're really serious about being a
[__] comedian
not an improp troop not a podcast I'm
talking about really being a [__]
comic like Joey I want to be a [__]
comic this is it there's no girlfriends
there's no Road manager
there's nobody carrying your luggage
there's no room service in these hotels
there's the smell of [__] Curry
okay here we're going to check into a
hotel and smell [__] Carrie in the
gym and the jacuzzi in your bed that's
what the [__] smell of okay
you know I had wild Bilbao and uh this
kid Bill Bauer God bless the soul while
Bill Bowe was the comedian there was a
kid Bill Bauer out of Colorado Springs
Colorado Springs no Greeley
and we were dear friends I reached out
to him maybe three years ago
and thank them for everything he did for
me because this guy would pay me my rent
and I would have to work off the rent
every month with gigs you know you have
so many of those people that come into
your life in your journey but to Fast
Track to that Journey I'm telling you
right now guys is those [__] triple
runs it is an experience it's like I
always say to people I don't know if I
could deal with Mercy I don't even know
if I'll be [__] alive
but I've heard other parents say this
I wish for me for me for my best my for
my best results as a comic was a human
being
I would love to hold my daughter back
from school for a year her first college
year that freshman year in college I
wish I had the nerve
and I wish I could hold them back from
that and make her become a Salesman I
don't care what it is
[__] lingerie
makeup cars
encyclopedias I don't give a [__] bras
Victoria's Secret
I think the biggest education for her
would be a year anybody this is my
opinion I think it would be to sell to
learn how to interact with the public to
learn how to deal with issues to learn
how to hustle to learn how to [__] go
wow it's the 28th of the month and I get
a check on the fifth I got three days to
sell a [__] picture of Bruce Lee
how am I going to sell it to pay rent
and guess what like the man says you
know you always uh what's that [__]
expression Rolling Stones
you can't always get what you want but
guess what [__] you get what you
need trust me I was a Salesman I know
what it's like to need 400 by Friday but
you get 350.
and you go to yourself well I got my
rent but I don't have groceries you know
what I could eat the curtain I'll eat
the [__] curtain I'll do anything you
know what I'm saying
that's a whole education guys that's an
education you're never going to get in
college and then you send them to
college with that education of being out
there for a year dealing with people
learning that people lie I'll be back
later yeah we'll buy the car tomorrow
[__] you I'm then you see him with a
Volkswagen and you're like what the [__]
I thought you hated German people you
know it's it's [__] non-stop you need
that and I'm gonna tell you something if
I look at any single thing that helped
me become a good [__] comedian
it was those triple runs because you
learn how to write
you learn how to adjust listen
[Music]
when you when triple calls you and he
goes to you okay you're gonna do the
potato run it's four nights
and you agree to it
you don't really know what's happening
until that fax comes in the mail for me
it was a fact for you it'll be a text on
Instagram post who the [__] knows but
when you get that sheet and you look at
the dates on the nights you know Tuesday
Thursday Friday and Saturday let's say
you have Wednesday off
that Thursday might say that hey
this club is a [__] violent Club
if something happens leave the stage
hide in the [__] broom closet you
know [__] like that can you imagine me
telling you on a [__] Tuesday that
the place you're walking into on
Thursday they might throw a bottle at
you you let me [__] rooms I [__]
went to Triple runs and they had you
ever see the movie The Blues Brothers
with the fence in the front and when
they're playing they're throwing bottles
at them and [__] I did three [__]
triple runs where they had that one of
them being Craig Colorado I'll never
forget Craig whatsoever it's [__]
etched in my mind
but it taught me how to deal with all
that [__] as a comic how to deal with
hecklers how to if you [__] give a
Heckler light he's gonna talk more how
to shut them down without insulting him
how to shut them down back Hey listen
you're embarrassing your wife brother
look at your wife she's [__] pink in
the face give her a breathe and then
yeah and then they stop it's [__]
amazing when you say [__] like that
about their wives you know how they stop
what do you think I learned this in a
book what do you think Judy Carter
taught me this would stand up [__]
comedy no
you had to go out there and [__] do
it
and triple had these rooms that were
just rough
unless you're Charlie Chan with a hat
and you're white and you eat chewing
tobacco guess what you don't fit in this
[__] rooms because all those rooms
are Wyoming Nebraska no not Nebraska
that's a different book all those book
is uh [__] uh
you know Montana
like if you like Yellowstone you'll like
David triple runs because you're all
over Montana Butte [__] Helena you're
all over those [__] you're all
over Idaho that's why he's got the
potato runs you're all over [__] yeah
they call potato run one and two and
[__]
yeah
he's the deal he's got bro he's got
Raven Tribble had a room across the
street from her room
so if you did potato run one you did
this room on a Tuesday night
when you dip potato room potato run two
the following week you did the room
across the street on a Thursday night so
you were here on Tuesday and nine nights
later you were here how do I know that
because I got arrested I did Idaho Falls
on a Tuesday night and I threw aquarot I
didn't throw them out the club Owners
room
he was saying [__] about being a New
Yorker like hey you [__] New York
[__] I'm like shut the [__] up
and the owner throws them out
I don't even think about it I finished
my show listen the shows are not you
know coming to the show and there's no
DJ with Chappelle it's just you
think I don't know what your name is
coming to the stage
Joey Diaz
he's from Colorado
and you walk out there [__] cold and
they'll tell you like most of your
audience is a Mormon
they're [__] Mormon that whole part
of the country I had a whole all that
[__] there's a lot of Mormons up there
how's your comedy gonna work up there in
your mind you're defeated as soon as you
walk into the [__] room
that's what gets you going the open mics
are great and getting into an improv is
great and getting into an helium is
great and getting into Joe Rogan's
mothership is great but let me tell you
what's better
when you're walking into those [__]
rooms and you're learning how to create
from scratch
from scratch because when you start
reading these sheets and they tell you
that your audience is going to be Mormon
this and this your mind takes over and
once your mind takes over it's just
pointing at at [__] death like you
know I'm gonna die in that room I'm
gonna die in that room then you get
there and the headline is no better than
you
the headline is like yeah you didn't do
nothing
I know you I haven't done dick you're
better than the headline you learn so
much you learn what to have in your car
you learn how to sleep out
you learn how to [__] sneak into a
Hilton and take a shower you know how to
jump into the pool and getting like
you're not a little pool area where they
have like Q-tips and [__] you don't want
to pay for a hotel room you say 30 but
triple runs teach you so [__] much
about life and the the nuts and bolts
that even if you take a comedy class
like I was talking to this guy and he
took somebody's comedy class and help
them but between the three and five year
mark as a comic
you have
so many questions
like what's your next move guys I wish I
could start a Consulting business or
some kind of Comedy agency where we can
answer all these questions for you I
don't have the [__] time you know I
got Lee I got you know I got a couple
guys I got my wife I got my daughter I'm
trying to put my life together I got
this book I wish I wish you know
but that's that's one thing how you get
better and starting your own rooms I've
said this over and over again guys
nobody's going to hand you the key to
the golden [__] thing you know one
thing even Lee said to me a couple weeks
ago he was like one thing I learned
about New York is you're never gonna get
nowhere unless you have your own room
and you're promoting your own room
that's an education guys that is an
education also going on the roads in
education taking a comedy class in
education but [__] starting your own
room oh my God no budget you got to pay
the comics who's not going to get drunk
who wants drink tickets
but it's the nitty-gritty you learn how
to book a [__] room from A to Z you
learn audiences I mean guys listen
I had a great time doing all those shows
with Rogue and an Ari and being at the
comedy store
but when I sit here some nights and I
think about comedy as a whole
I look at the adventures I had when I
was [__] struggling how much fun it
was to figure out how to put together a
gig for 125 dollars when you're getting
fifty dollars a gig you're like how am I
gonna up my status all these little
[__] things was so interesting to me
you know if there's not a [__] week I
don't think about that little Chinese
guy I used to torture in in Boulder you
know little Ron Jesus Christ that was
fun
that was just fun man I would go in
there on Mondays I knew his night off
was Monday so I go in there on Wednesday
and tell them I'm gonna bring you Bill
Cosby
no
Bill Cosby here
how much 20 000.
but I'll take a thousand dollars deposit
today okay I'll be right back you give
me a thousand bucks dog
his night off was Mondays
so I get like a black football play and
walk in there into the Chinese
restaurant make sure the other waiters
saw me and the [__] Chinese lady
and I go I brought you know Bill Cosby
he's not here
tell him and also I go back two days
later I came in here with Bill Cox I
know they told me when is he coming back
I go he's not you forfeited the [__]
money
I had to go in there with a straight
face and tell this guy I gotta go in
there with a straight [__] face you
learn how to go into a [__] bar and
how to you how many [__] bars I had
when in Boulder you know where I had a
bar that I forgot all about telling you
guys I had a [__] night a one-nighter
in
The Canyon Club
gotta go back 15 years ago this is
between
2008 2007
and maybe 2010 it was right before I met
Lee
guys I was struggling
it was a zero proposition deal I didn't
make a dime till they came in I had to
get a beer sponsor to give me a hundred
dollars a week
that's how I paid the [__] Comics
would it be a sponsor they gave me a
hundred bucks and the [__] club owner
gave me a hundred bucks you know how
much money I made nothing
nothing it was a night out it was a
night out of comedy and I got to pay a
headline to come up I'd have like Rick
dukeman come up
I had to have like Ralphie May come up I
had Ralphie do it like 10 times because
I didn't have to pay him so we just keep
the [__] money I would call Ralphie
every other week come up and work out we
got chicken cutlets up here whatever the
[__] he liked up there these are the
things you got to do to move forward
guys get your own room nobody's giving
you rooms okay nobody's giving you spots
don't walk into any [__] bar
I could if I wasn't as lazy as I was now
I mean listen we don't have a lot of
entertainment bars here and uh this side
of New Jersey by me you have the uh
Ballroom in Sayreville that's like a big
rock
starlands Ballroom which I heard they
might start doing comedy
that would be it is a good spot I heard
it's a great spot and they have a budget
you know but they don't have like a
little bar with a a little stage and a
microphone maybe they have like karaoke
or something one night a week a couple
old people you're going there each other
guys I'm not looking for a dime I'm just
looking to come in here on Tuesdays and
do 20 minutes
are you funny uh you know you got to
tell them whatever [__] [__]
story you got to tell them yeah I'm kind
of funny but nobody's gonna give you
anything nobody if you think you know
you're gonna get a business card to
headshot and tell people I'm a comic and
that's it the phone's gonna ring listen
it's not gonna work out for you or I'll
call Joe Diaz and he'll take me on the
road with me that's not gonna work for
you either all these things are not
going to work for you it's not going to
work for you and like that's what this
kid was saying to me you know I always
do spots that stand up New York I was
hoping one of the comics would take me
on the road listen that's a great dream
and it's going to happen somebody will
take you on the road I promise you that
if you do the work and you show up at
the clubs with a great attitude and
you're not a [__] mooc somebody will
take you on the [__] road trust me
but let's say they don't
let's say they don't what are you going
to do wait there for the [__] phone
to ring just like anything in life
you're not it's 2023. you're not gonna
just sit there and wait for the [__]
phone number it's too competitive out
there too many people moving around you
listen you can't even take a [__]
breather you cannot take a breather
today in your career I haven't done [__]
in [__] three years stand up wise
I don't know half these people
I look at these schedules for The Comedy
Store and this and that
I don't know these people
I have no hatred for them I don't I'm
not hating on them or anything I don't
know them
you know what that tells me that tells
me things are moving [__] quickly
things are moving [__] quickly when I
look at the comedy sell a schedule and I
know two people out of 20. when I look I
look at The Comedy Store schedule that
they posted on something I knew three
people
they would just put the top 20 Comics at
The Comedy Store I knew maybe four of
those people
I don't know these people
that's how fast this game [__] moves
so it could either [__] move by you
or you could get on the [__] bus it's
up to you and most people are scared to
get on the bus they're waiting for a bus
that wish they never [__] comes
because they don't want to get on anyway
they just they enjoy saying oh I go to
acting class I do scene study I do next
week we're doing a scene from Jerry
Maguire [__] Jerry Maguire you want to
do a scene from a new [__] movie
nobody wants to do that stupid [__] I
did asking class for a couple [__]
months and then somebody told me get the
[__] out of there because you're gonna
rot your brain it's true those kids will
be stuck in there for 20 years being a
[__] acting assistant coach to help
them out to to volunteer [__] that they
ain't no volunteering in your [__]
world guys you guys are playing for
[__] keeps here no matter what the
[__] you're doing but back to Comedy
guys
get on the guy's name is David Tribble I
forget what the [__] name of this
company is
it will
make you a comic in ways that you never
thought and it's still it's you're gonna
be mad at yourself because you're not
gonna
you're gonna go this was not the path I
thought it was I thought it was going to
be [__] and green rooms and Rick
James and people rubbing my feet not at
all nobody gives a [__] about you and
that's a good thing nobody's paying
attention
you go in there and try your [__]
materials and walk the [__] out of there
nobody will ever see you again
we think people are going to leave
Montana to go see you in LA
I saw him eight years ago in Billings
let's go see him on Broadway that's not
gonna happen you think any of those
people remember when I went into those
rooms and bombed not at all you think
one of those people hit me up on
Facebook I remember you 20 years ago you
came in here and told the joke about
Godzilla it was the worst joke I ever
had no
they forget about you the final [__]
week and that's what you want you know
you don't want people to [__]
remember you you just want to go in
there and tell your jokes gauge your
comedy see where the [__] is that and
move the [__] none and the eight-hour
drive that's all part of the struggle
you learn to see the [__] country I
never bitched once about that
it just let me know when I was ready for
airplanes
that's what that tells you now I'm ready
for airplanes when you incorporate a 500
plane ticket a 500 a week of comedy and
you're like how am I going to pay 400
dollars
fly there and break a hundred dollar you
know that's not even uh that's not even
doable
so everything has to go up you'll know
when to take a plane when not I mean
Frontier Right is open offering that
sixty dollars a month
and you fly whatever you want but you
know God knows of your land God knows if
you fly because there's No Reservations
you just [__] show up there and
you know hope for the best so I I don't
know what to tell you but
start with a [__] Comedy Room start
with your own Comedy Room guys see we
take ourselves too seriously
and we have to find these Exquisite
[__] locales and no you don't you're
a comic all you need is a brick wall a
microphone and four [__] people in
the audience and you can work your magic
Joey four [__] you two I love you four
four is a good night
two and you just totally own I want to
come in here every [__] night and do
it listen I did it in Boulder I used to
do 16 cents a month in Boulder which is
[__] but all those rooms were not Taj
Mahal's they were an Australian bar one
was a [__] bar that was
as dark as that you couldn't even see
the guy on the [__] stage with the
microphone one place was a [__] sound
recording studio in the back of a bar
that only sat 16 people and it was like
you were in a fiberglass you know those
when they put those that [__] on the
walls the tape it's like a foam and [__]
like you were breathing as bestos while
you were in there you're like is my lung
gonna blow up while I'm [__] in here
I mean it's amazing but it doesn't
matter
it's not your final destination
it's just a stepping stone and then the
Improv the Laugh Factory the comedy
Mothership The Comedy Store they'll be
your final destination don't get
yourself down you listen I don't give a
[__] what the ball looks like
you're just working
you're getting a set and look at it as
one last set you gotta do 5 000 sets to
get to your [__] location you're just
adding to a set it doesn't matter it
doesn't say anywhere oh well Dave
Chappelle says you got to do five
thousand sets on improv no it doesn't
you can do these sets anywhere for any
amount the growth is still going to be
in your corner so don't sit there stuck
start lifting the [__] rock and start
thinking for yourself guys because time
is moving the [__] by that's how all
this [__] lately I've been reading the
UFC Channel with uh you know Connor not
whatever the [__] he's not in the pool
or what I don't even know what the
[__] going on there but you know guys
listen every week you could throw as
many punches as you want I could I could
write as many jokes as I want I could be
the best [__] joke writer in the
world but if I'm not bringing them to a
stage and I'm not gapping them together
and [__] throwing them out there I'm
not really being a comic
so right now I'm not being a comic it's
passing me by
every night that I stay off stage it
passes Me by one of the reasons why
Donald and I really connected as
Comedians and his friends afterwards
because somebody told me
that's really interesting he goes I
looked it because Dom was a basketball
guy too
and he goes I look at my comedy career
as when I looked at basketball
if I wasn't out there doing it somebody
is
so just remember that while you're
[__] around with your girlfriend
thinking you're cute oh I'm gonna be a
comedian somebody else is out there
being a [__] comedian even if it's in
front of four [__] people and a dive
bar with where Hawaiian straw darts at
you have you ever been to a bar where
there's a dark thing behind you and
people throw [__] darts at it and you
get hit with those no you haven't I have
have you ever done comedy or bar where
the stage is the door and every time the
door opens up somebody has to walk
around you in the stage dog these are
all the things I had to do I don't want
to hear your [__] [__] you know
the Japanese I mean I wasn't I was in
[__] uh
sumoville
Oceanside California with Darren Carter
and somebody threw a Rambo knife up at
the stage and it stuck against the
[__] wall have you ever done comedy
there Darren Carter is a great comedian
you know
these are the things you got to go
through guys get ready to suffer enjoy
the suffering once the suffering is gone
you reach your destination that's how
you know you're there and they're still
going to be suffering but it's not going
to be as hard as when you were [__]
sneaking into a you know I would sneak
into [__] uh karaoke rooms and tell
them I want to sing [__] uh what is
what's that song I don't know [__]
being there I don't [__] know some
Happy song I tell them I want to sing
[__] and also I go up there and pray
he put the music on and I just grabbed
the mic and start cracking jokes what's
up you [__] and he can he be
yelling that's not the lyrics to the
song because it was like some English
guy
we do what we [__] do [__] the
main thing is we push [__] forward
that's your Monday motivation for the
10th of April
time keeps moving the book will be ready
May 2nd order your books now
tremendous the stories of a comedy
Savage on Amazon and this somewhere else
where it's free shipping I forget check
my Instagram and that's it and that's
that I love you [__] thank you
for checking in
thank you for having my back and have a
great [__] week and I'll see you
[__] next Monday tip top Magoo
all right you Savages I want to thank
you for listening to the Monday morning
motivation ear beating before I go don't
forget this weekend we got NBA playoffs
starting oh this week better yet that
means it's time to fire up the
DraftKings Sportsbook app and get it on
the excitement guys I like Memphis this
year
there's a couple themes I like Philly
but hey new customers can make a five
dollar pregame money blind bet and if
your team wins you score 150 in bonus
bets who's better than you nobody it's
the no sweat game same game parlay every
day during the NBA Playoffs just open up
the DraftKings Sportsbook app plays the
same game parlay on any NBA game if it
doesn't hit you get 10 bucks who's
better than you DraftKings that's who
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
now and sign up with code Joey
j-o-e-y new customers can make a five
dollar pregame moneyline bet and score
150 in bonus bets if their team wins
only at DraftKings sports book with code
Joey j-o-e-y you got a gambling problem
call 1-800 Gambler in Massachusetts
1-800-327-50
5-0 and in Kansas
1-800-522-4700 but if you ain't got a
problem let's download the app and let's
get the party started the joint is also
brought to you by manscape listen if you
don't know April is testicular cancer
awareness month it's a common form of
cancer in men ages 15 to 35. one man
every hour every day gets diagnosed
manscape has teamed up with the
testicular cancer society to bring
awareness to Men's Health and and early
cancer detection is part of that we save
balls initiative shave your balls and
save your balls by checking for cancer
every time you use your manscape
products for a limited time you can also
get a manscape special edition purple
testicular cancer society lawnmower 4.0
electric waterproof trimmer
[__] that was long anyway take care of
your balls of manscape and be sure to
check for cancer at least once a month
get 20 off for plus free shipping with
code Joey at manscape.com again that's
20 off from free shipping with code Joey
at manscape.com I want to thank manscape
DraftKings and better hope and I want to
thank you savages for always having my
back stay black have a great week and
I'll see you [__] next Monday
[Music]
thank you